[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback senior NFL reporter and he
joins us on the program let's give
Albert the poll question for hour two
there see no Connor
our Tool uh poll question Dan okay the
Arizona Cardinals are tanking and hope
we didn't notice tanking and don't care
if we notice or not tanking at all not
trying to win all right let me start
with that question for you Albert
I don't think they care that we know
that they're tanking because
I think like it's actually just the
right thing to do stripping that roster
down and I I mean look like all you have
to do is look at like what they had the
last few years under Cliff Kingsbury
guys like AJ Green and JJ Watt and
Rodney Hudson who you know we're great
players in their time but we're well
past their Prime they were like leaning
on these guys you know so I mean I
understand like you know the idea like
oh they're tanking for Caleb Williams or
Drake May and there's Merit to the idea
of that of course but you know I like I
sort of look at this like what else did
you want them to do yeah you know like
it's not like they had this option where
they were closed and it's like yeah
let's go after it I mean the right thing
to do here was to strip the thing down
and and really hit reset and start over
and I think that was like apparent it
was blatantly apparent in the way that
they handle the draft you know I think
Monty Austin fought their GM did a good
job of moving up and down to get the guy
they wanted in Paris Johnson and pick up
another another first round pick for
next year
um and now they're positioned well for
the future but it's not like like
anybody else would have come in there
and done anything different like this is
always going to be a total rebuild it's
just where that roster was at okay what
do you do with Kyler Murray if he's not
active today then he's not coming back
to at least week five and his motivation
would be to win games so you're not
getting Caleb Williams and the ownership
might be you know contrasting that that
they want to lose games so it's
something's you know there's going to be
a head-on collision here I would think
yeah you know it's hard because there's
all kinds of injury guarantees in his
contract and the injury guarantees run
through 2025 and if you look at it like
I mean you know good for Kyler because
this thing gives him protection every
step of the way he's got over 35 million
dollars fully guaranteed next year the
year after that there's almost 30
million dollars that becomes guaranteed
fully guaranteed in March so essentially
the
the the the Cardinals have to make a
decision on 30 million dollars of
Kyler's Murray for 2025 about what seven
months from now you know so you're
talking then about like what would be
Caleb Williams or Drake may his second
year in the league and you'd be carrying
like that 30 million dollar number on
your books if you don't offload him by
March so
I I think certainly this is a critical
year for Kyler Murray and he's protected
financially but I mean if you go down
the line on this and you look at it I
mean there's going to be a decision
Point that's going to come and one way
or the other it's going to be costly for
the Cardinals to keep Kyle and Murray
it's going to be costly for the for the
Cardinals to get rid of Kyler Murray and
um you know I think you can give Kyle
and his agent a lot of credit for
rattling cages like they did last year
because now he is protected six ways
from Sunday no matter what the Cardinals
do would he be tradable if he's healthy
I
I don't know I mean it's just they ran
such a unique offense the last three
years under Cliff Kingsbury and look
what Drew pet sing their offensive
coordinator is going to bring in
um you know under Jonathan Gannon is
completely different and I mean In
fairness of Kyler my understanding is
Kyler's been really engaged as far as
learning it because what Cliff had him
doing the last three years was sort of a
continuation of the offense he ran for
Lincoln Riley at Oklahoma and then the
high the the offense he ran before that
in high school even when he ran for
Kevin someone at Texas A M all those
years ago
um so this was the most this has been
the most significant schematic change
that Kyler Murray's gone through in
maybe his entire Football Life and so
he's engaged in that and I do think like
for Kyler playing this year and showing
that he can run a version of the the
Shanahan offense with Drew petson coming
there from Cleveland would certainly
make him more marketable as a player and
would help help the Cardinals as far as
like convincing somebody else to take on
this contract now would they have to eat
some money probably
um but I think that that's like a key
part to this because again we've only
seen him in sort of an air raid type of
system and we don't know what he would
look like in a more conventional system
or what ninety percent of the rest of
the NFL runs so having that context is
going to be important which I think
makes for Kyler for the Cardinals for
everybody an important you know getting
to see what he looks like in that sort
of offense when we get to October
November December whenever he's ready to
come back why did the Cowboys trade for
treylands
well number one Jerry's always had a
fascination with these things and if you
look at the history of it it really is
interesting
um Dan like I you remember what Jerry
like went and brought in all these
baseball players you know it's like
Quincy Carter and Drew Henson and Chad
Hutchinson and you know he kept taking
swings on guys who are highly regarded
but had gone to play Minor League
Baseball
um Jerry has always I think sort of had
a fascination with like how can I find
the next guy and is there a rock that I
can turn over
um is there a way that I can find my
next version of Tony Romo or Dak
Prescott and so even when he's had a
quarterback he likes in the roster he's
gone about doing that and I think that's
part of what this is because they had a
high grade on Trey Lance you know I
think to some degree you feel like
you're acquiring a distressed asset here
and you got to pay five million dollars
next year in 2024 to do it but there is
some logic there that it's never a bad
investment to take a swing at that
position because it can wind up being
worth a lot more to you and if Trey
Lance develops nicely under Mike
McCarthy and then has a good preseason
next year maybe you can recoup the pick
um so that part of it I you know that
that's part of it if you want to be a
little more cynical about it you can
also look at like what this might mean
for Dak Prescott and how contentious the
last contract negotiation got and how
he's going to be going into a contract
here in 2024 and how they have to take
care of this at some point you know and
so to me like that part of it is at
least interesting like where do we go
from here and could Trey Lance
eventually be a leverage point for the
Cowboys against Dak Prescott and
contract negotiations that's what I'm
looking at here and I think that that
part of it makes this really really
fascinating going forward
um especially if the Cowboys have a new
head coach in 2024
but you know Trey Lance isn't better
than Cooper Rush
yeah well but that's why you're not but
you're not acquiring them for death
you're acquiring them because you think
you can become more than that you know
what I mean like you're not acquiring
him so he can fill in for Dak Prescott
in week five if if that gets nicked up
so why are you why are you bringing him
in you're bringing him in because you
think he's got upside need more than
that and you think that maybe he got
caught and you know bad circumstance in
San Francisco and you're acquiring that
distressed asset you think you can make
him into something and if you can make
him into something maybe he can give you
some leverage in that contract
negotiation against that yeah that's
sort of where they stand but he's got to
learn a whole new offense he didn't get
a chance to play he's not going to get a
chance to play in Dallas and
like how do you work him in to getting
any action when he's not and that's the
problem see that would be the argument I
would make Dan like is that like what
everybody in San Francisco would tell
you he needs to play and that's one of
the reasons why the Niners can't can't
like like really like felt like it
wasn't right for them right now because
they don't have an environment that he
can play in and the whole thing in San
Francisco was we need to get him snaps
and if you talk to people in that
building last August but they would tell
you like Point Blank and this is before
the Jimmy renegotiation when he was off
in the side practice field they would
have told you then Jimmy Garoppolo is a
better quarterback than Trey Lance right
now but we believe if we can feed Trey
game reps that by December or January
we'll have a better quarterback than
Trey Lance and then we'll be set up for
the future and we'll be able to expand
Kyle shanan's offense and do more than
we've ever done yeah now then Trey Lance
gets hurt and you know they were willing
to go through the ups and downs and
everything else that comes with
developing a Young quarterback but Trey
Lance gets hurt and then Jimmy comes in
Jimmy plays fine Jimmy gets hurt Brock
Purdy comes in and he shows that he can
run Kyle Shanahan's offense like say
they would have envisioned Mac Jones
running their offense
so now you're looking at it and you're
saying can we put another year in Peril
to run an offense that doesn't work for
everybody that works for Trey Lance and
take our lumps and go through our ups
and downs and trade lines especially now
when he's lost confidence or lost some
confidence like
is that fair to Trent Williams is that
fair to Fred Warner is that fair to Nick
Bosa no they're they're in a
championship window they can't afford to
throw a year overboard or risk throwing
a year overboard the name of quarterback
development so they couldn't afford him
the snaps he's only played 21 games
since high school since two and that's
that's the last you know five and a half
years so but it's the same situation
with Dallas because he's going into a
team that's right a Super Bowl Contender
and and that's the hard part that's the
hard part like and it's like if you
aren't if you haven't invested three
first-round picks in a guy like San
Francisco did who's going to be willing
to go through the bumps the UPS the
Downs like that's where you're between a
rock and a hard place if you're Trey
Lance you need the game wraps but
without having somebody who's that
invested in you who's going to give them
to you I thought Minnesota would have
been a great spot for him
right but what do you have gotten the
Reps there I don't know but I think he's
got a better chance of getting reps
there than he does in Dallas because
Jerry Jerry is on the doorstep I mean
he's desperate to win a Super Bowl and
you can't just say to Trey Lance go in
there when Cooper Rush is better than
him if Dak happens to play poorly or uh
gets hurt so right it's uh it's hard
yeah it's hard it's just I mean like and
that's the thing is like it's a unique
situation in that like this is a guy who
just has not seen enough and Brock Purdy
was the opposite of that by the way like
Brock Purdy had something like 14 or
1500 attempts in college you know
are you are you all in on Brock Purdy
I'm I'm all in on the Niners roster and
I don't think Brock turkey needs to be a
superhero to make it work yes
I like look like I do I think Brock
Purdy Brock Purdy got them to the NFC
title game last year and then he got
hurt Okay and like I just look at
they're not asking Brock Purdy to be a
superhero now what's going to be
fascinating about this is
do you believe now Dan that we're in an
environment where Joe Flacco couldn't
win a Super Bowl anymore Eli Manning
couldn't win a Super Bowl anymore a
second year Russell Wilson couldn't win
a Super Bowl anymore let alone like Brad
Johnson or Trent Dale for winning a
Super Bowl do you believe that do you
need Mahomes do you need Alan because
there used to be a time where if you
were good enough around the quarterback
you could win you could beat the team
with great quarterbacks but because of
the environment the game the way the
games went gone the rules all that
different stuff like can you not do that
anymore to me the Niners are going to be
a good test of that because I do think
Brock Purdy is a good quarterback do I
think like if they had equal rosters
that he could beat Josh Allen or Joe
burrow or Patrick Mahomes no
do I think he might be able to make it
through the NFC sure like I think he
might be able to make it through the NFC
you know
um so I I think it's going to be a
fascinating experiment you know and I
think he's got a chance like they feel
like I'll just tell you this in San
Francisco they feel like he can give
them what Matt Jones would have given
them if they had taken Matt Jones sort
of overall and Matt Jones was a serious
consideration for them at Certo it was a
third overall pick and that's what sort
of saves them here now can Brock Purdy
carry a team I think that's a different
question what's like Jalen hurts he's
got a great roster but if Jalen hurts
you know played in Houston people would
say oh that guy is kind of interesting
there it's if you played in Kansas City
could he have taken that Kansas City
team to a Super Bowl probably not right
I I don't know it's it's I I tell people
about where you get drafted and
sometimes the later you get drafted at
that position the better off you are
because you get a little time there's
not as much pressure Trey Lance couldn't
live up to that pressure I get that but
Dak Prescott hey you know our third or
fourth round pick or Russell Wilson and
you're a third round pick it you know
Brady it allows you to kind of absorb
and then be able when you get your
moment to produce I don't know if Jalen
hurts is great I know he's on a great
team I know he had an unbelievable Super
Bowl well
and even the gray one even like the guys
who become great players like there are
very few quarterbacks that are good
enough to overcome bad circumstances to
me like that's why Andrew Luck is so
underappreciated right like look at what
Andrew Luck walked into they tore that
roster down you know like after Bill
pulling and and Jim Caldwell were fired
they tore that roster down and Andrew
Luck made the playoffs as a rookie and
then made it around further in year two
and around for a year further around for
around further in year three and then
the injuries started to mount up because
he didn't have a lot around him and he
was getting beat up and I just there are
very few quarterbacks that can do that
you know and as great as Mahomes is
Mahomes went into an awesome
circumstance as great as Josh Allen as
Josh Allen went to an awesome
circumstance right like burrow I think
he could argue
burrow was dealing with a little more
like a little bit more of an issue
around him and his offensive line but he
had great play he a great receivers to
throw to you know it's rare that you
find a quarterback that can overcome a
bad circumstance and so yeah I mean I
think that you're right like the chicken
and egg thing is very very real at the
quarterback position
Jonathan Taylor get moved today
yeah I think that like part of this is
going to come down to um whether or not
the Colts are willing to take a little
less like they don't have their price
right now they may get it but they don't
have their price right now
um and then like where Jonathan Taylor's
contract demands are now I I like I'd
heard like that but maybe between 13 and
14 million a year and uh 40 million over
the first three years of a deal could
get it done that seems reasonable to me
the question is is somebody willing to
do that and then give her away say like
a second round pick and something else
yeah
that's a lot you know and it's a lot at
this point of the year so I still think
Miami's the team to watch and what's
interesting about Miami to me Dan is the
reason why
um we know that offense like right like
Mike McDaniel running like the Mike
Shanahan offense has been able to I mean
I'm not saying you or I could run for a
thousand yards in it but that's probably
not far off like if you look at the
history going back 25 years to when Mike
ran it in Denver
um so we've always known that like you
can that that running game works almost
regardless of who's back there carrying
the ball uh but I think Mike McDaniel
saw what Christian McCaffrey was able to
do in San Francisco last year
and I just sort of wonder if like
there's that part of it for him where
it's like he looks at what Kyle was able
to do with a truly Elite back and
Christian McCaffrey and it's just sort
of like I wonder what someone like that
could do for me and Jonathan Taylor
would obviously be that for them and
there's no question that over the last
year so they've really taken their
swings and going and getting Tyree kill
and going and getting Jalen Ramsay so
this would be along the lines of of how
they've taken advantage of having a
quarterback into a on a rookie contract
always great to talk to you Albert thank
you for joining us again all right
thanks Dan that's the Monday Morning
Quarterback Albert Brier